Why diversity training is a waste of time.
It's because it goes against human nature.
You are naturally attracted to other people
who are similar to you. I am too.
Think about religion, politics,
sports teams,
cultural backgrounds. Right?
We like things that are like us. Period.
So we talk about joining like minded individuals.
And that's what we want in our team.
But we also want diversity.
So what to do instead?
Teach and learn about emotional intelligence.
Teach and learn about holding each other accountable
for nasty behaviors in the workplace.
Training only works
when the problem is lack of knowledge.
So providing diversity training with no assessment
of what is really the root of the problem.
It's a poor use of your organization's money.
You've got this.